hello welcome to hey [ __ ] podcast hey
big [ __ ] and hey oh and I guess [ __ ]
shows what do you want I don't know the
mail for squares I feel like the Mitch's
I feel like [ __ ] is a general term like
mailman or a human you know I like mail
woman but that's just my own preference
mail woman yeah why does it have to be
separate why can't we just have like
then we can call of a male women I know
you're like you got like Spanish and
like you know I like Spanish wait I like
it or I was like language is like very
male female or you yeah and I hate the
whole I hate the whole let's just
introduce who the [ __ ] is you alright
roll call I do I'm the one that doesn't
like Spanish the one that loves Spanish
I'm Bo isn't I like English I'm Megan I
can barely speak any of the languages
correctly oh my god you're the first
guest that has ever introduced
themselves I'm so embarrassed right now
we needed to do we are here with our
good friend youtuber dancer yes
DIY extra yaaaaay extraordinaire keep it
coming the Millennial Joanne you Joanna
Gaines I could remember her name was
Joanna Joanna and I remember the last
minute and I don't know that much about
what Megan does but she's fine okay we
were having a conversation and like she
was looking at me and I was like really
pretty good yeah it was like
conversation as well you're really
preface is very symmetric okay and
you're not watching on YouTube you are
missing out yeah or while you're
listening just pull the picture of her
and just look at it
plug your Instagram what is it it's at
Megan batoon it's at Smosh can you
imagine that is that for her no I do
that all the time when people like kills
from small I know they'll comment on my
a photos and logo like oh you have a
YouTube channel where is it I'll go it
Smosh I always like other people's
YouTube channels and you're like I want
why Grosso see like all the comments on
swatches last poster Mike where's Megan
my managers like this is bad business
it's funny to me so Megan you currently
dating anyone
oh right in there yeah hell yeah what
make it awkward what do you consider
dating oh because you know it's
different now like talking to and dating
it's all different okay would you bring
like them to a barbecue and okay well
I'll just like to tell you about him in
like a broader sense of like these are
kind of the men that I date yes so
they're comedians and I think that's
where I hope my main problem yeah that's
how many people have told me to stop
dating comedians I just keep on doing it
right what's wrong with got it touch the
stove no you don't want to know I mean I
I'm married to a comedian I mean not
stand-up car yeah okay yeah so I think
at least with stand-ups and I really
hope no stand-up is watching and being
mad at me for saying this but like their
job is to kind of figure out what's
wrong with things to see things that are
not good about something and so it's
like and then make it a joke yeah
inherently not optimistic its realism in
like a very malicious way so you should
date a prop comic what like me triumphs
done who's the one that [ __ ] smashes
water Mel Gallagher
yeah there we go what is it about
comedians that you keep getting yourself
into the situation it's such a good
question my therapist now it's it is it
the comedy or is it the sadness and
vulnerability ooh
cuz I'm there for that yeah I want
everybody to sad and vulnerable around
its like comedians keep going right
they're always done to drink like yeah
literally always on the drink always
down to party like there's always
there's always some kind of drama going
on it's fun and it's exhilarating but I
mean when is it free go I don't know I
mean I do like to laugh a lot but I
realize like
you don't have to date a comedian -
laughs right the thing is if you can
laugh during sex I want to marry you
like jokes during sex
hello can I get an example of a joke I
made a joke during sex yesterday my
boyfriend went saw you got back on the
couch and we were both quiet and I was
like can I tell you how I'm feeling
right and then we had a really great
community could dip discussion where I
had to be like was it me or was it was
it one of those words like is it inside
because I can't feel anything no no no
no I thought that made like a cute joke
and he told me that it took his mind out
of sexy time and like he like and he it
was hard for him to go back into it try
harder yeah exactly
okay so last night yeah we have a trust
thing like so I married a comedian after
swearing I would never date a comedian
again because my previous boyfriend was
a comedian and he was awful so we have a
rule though because I we used to be like
I used to be like comfortable like that
and actually we used to I used to make
jokes that I would tell my stand-up set
during sex to him before we started
dating but then we started having sex
and I really didn't do that it was just
a joke but we have a rule because
there's like a trust where like if you
cross the line into like not making it
sexy time anymore when the other person
is committed to like doing dirty talk
and like you kiss dirty talks kind of
embarrassing if someone like calls you
out on it you know like you're like in
the middle if you're someone take it
seriously guys and then they're like
what was that what kind of sexy voice is
going on fill in the blanks yep yeah so
we can't call each other we can't like
make jokes when the other person is
trying to take it seriously otherwise
it's a gateway to like never taking it
seriously yeah and then like you don't
get to have that role play
aspect anymore right maybe it's because
I have never role played before there's
a problem yeah yeah so I think that like
it's not like a roast battle of jokes
it's just you imagine like before sex a
full-on roast battle and at the end of
it he's like I'm hard like your tits are
so weird well yeah I just I think you
can laugh in general maybe if you're not
talking dirty but you're just kind of
like in it and yes if you like if you
like naked and vulnerable and laughing
it's like that's the most you you could
ever be yeah and you've never had that
therefore when it does happen you're
gonna marry them I don't know I'm
talking about more like humility maybe
then yeah definitely like laugh during
sex and I can't even I can't even think
of a situation that it's been in but
it's just been like in a period where
like we're so happy that like something
really small happens that it just
becomes funny yeah you know I've had
that happen before but that's I mean I
thought it was cute all right cool you
shoot me I'll just I'll see myself out
is anyone gonna talk yet Matt I contact
with me somebody might jump in now I
make a lot of eye contact yeah I did so
much so that I felt like my boss there
jab at me the other day we're at a
restaurant and the waiter hadn't come
over for a minute and I was like okay
I'll I'll like try to make eye contact
with the musci was like yeah you're good
at that and I was like okay okay a lot
of eye contact so how did you meet this
guy that you don't know if you're dating
or not oh god no I'm like nervous to say
anything ever right I meet all of the
people that I've date
dated through other people which is like
my favorite form of meeting people but I
don't know I keep on like downloading
the dating apps and then they get
screenshot and put on Twitter so I have
to get off of that oh so like I feel
like I can't date anybody now hard yeah
cuz like I didn't think about you I'm
sorry well just understand that I've
been out of the game yeah right we got
two married people on here one's serious
relationship and then Megan and then
navigating the seas and that's why we
wanted to talk to you guys because it's
like you know it's like what what do you
look like
look for in a guy like in today is
dating pool gonna help me it's different
yeah it's really different though
because she find people through her
friends different for her in the dating
pool because she's like not a regular
person right you know like she said like
her [ __ ] get screenshot it gets blasted
everywhere so like her pool of people is
literally like totally I didn't mean
that sound though celebrity type of
dating apps were like oh god you get the
douchiest people on to you again dude
you get the douchey is people and then
they always make it a point to say like
we met on Brea like it's like they're
like I was accepted it didn't like oh
yeah the worst people gross yeah I don't
love but I feel like there's gross
people on every dating app what but
doesn't raya even have an option for
income what I think it does where you
can like display I get that or something
I understand how do you prove it you
have to send your taxes in or I don't
know I think that's a section on riot I
don't know correct me if I'm wrong but I
think it I don't want that kind of shows
you like how douchey it kinda is yeah
right or or like I've heard youtubers
will get on there to meet other people
to collab with oh yeah they're like a
work section I don't know how often that
works cause when you match on somewhere
I like nothing ever happens afterwards
like I know you I know of you know and
that's it huh yeah yeah man dating
sounds hard yeah well okay let's say but
well I want to help so okay okay what if
you like in your ideal world like in the
whole like if you had to put together
the perfect partner and he just comes
tumbling into your life somehow but what
would that look like okay here we go
I'm gonna go like kind of all like my I
have like a one of I guess mentor maybe
she was like think of it with your five
senses like yeah they look like sound
like King like smell like feel like sea
ice like
hey that's a big thing I did you ever
like date a guy with bad breath it's a
deal-breaker I was assured of licking
their own what I was seeing I was not
thinking that bad with this smell though
- like I've smelled my boyfriend's
armpit before because like his like I
don't know what is it pheromones
yeah oh there there and oh there they're
edible no yeah when if you like the
smell of their natural scent you're
supposed to be together chemically
you're compatible right from a mammal
stamp yeah I that's along all the men
that I date like smell so good they
smell like uh okay
that smells me imagine like scotch tape
yeah and then you said tape nose like
whoa I'm like okay popcorn scotch tape
and like sandalwood know what the smell
of scotch tape is but like damn dude I
love it almost clean but like in a it
has a Musk the the one that's like kind
of matte yeah plasticky yeah yeah with
sandalwood and some like trauma it might
be that sound the smell of trauma might
may be that scotch there might be like
some body wash something I had my gosh
okay so I had my toward the dantas a few
weeks ago when my boyfriend and I were
like having some issues stick his finger
into my mouth and he smelled so good but
I realized that I think you used the
same body wash as my boyfriend and then
I was like I don't I don't know who I
want right now
I must have strong smell of scotch tape
and sandalwood young and then you don't
kind of be a comedian but a good sense
of humor I think that's just like
obviously yes right no matter no matter
who you are as long as you can get along
with someone on a humor level then
you're so people have different
definitions of what a good sense yes
thought to say that I'm like Sophie
farts and he's cracking up
like I like it no not even that but like
um uh uh yeah I feel like if somebody if
you laugh if you both laugh after
somebody farts you guys have the same
yeah humor but if you don't then you
don't so like some guys when they would
be like oh yeah that girl has good sense
of humor and I'm like I know that girl
she's not funny right but they're know
they're talking about right off of no no
they judge off of if they if she laughs
at their jokes then they have a good
sense of humor that's like a good sense
of humor so then I learned
okay guys are describing a girl having a
good sense of humor or maybe it is vice
versa too but specifically guys have
told me this that oh no I didn't mean
she was funny I meant yes she has a good
sense of humor like she gets jokes would
meaning she gets his joke right yeah
yeah that's an interesting yes cuz when
I say a guy has a good sense of humor I
mean he makes me laugh
I mean yeah like he is funny right and
then I would assume if he's saying I
have a good summer that he thinks I'm
funny
also yeah not the case not the case but
the goal yes pay attention that before
this because I'm [ __ ] funny so I
don't need anything and I have a good
sense of humor or that I'm funny you
know just I just I know I could tell by
the way you laugh at your jokes for a
long time I spend so much time laughing
at my own jokes I don't know if anyone
else I laugh loud and home I love that
you'll never be alone okay so wanna go
away okay we have the humor humor
disgust smell like a good like it was it
that year since like the hearing yeah
because you're like hearing those oh
yeah yeah we can we can take that one
feel I feel like as if they feel like
home they feel like home and like if
they're able to make me feel taken care
of and gentle like with the more silly
the comedian the less they know how to
touch you and like I'll have some people
like touch me but they'll be like
like a heavy road like crazy like they
just don't understand like like top
that's not how to touch a girl I mean
but you look straight well they're like
she can hang I know I'm strong as out
but don't treat me like a coward
remember they're like oh yeah one of
those is a softball girl yeah that's not
gonna feel my light touch right I get
what you mean about like somebody
feeling like home because like I told I
told my god this one time and I think he
was offended I was but I meant the best
of this I was like when I'm with you I
feel like I'm alone like oh oh yeah but
like one another like I like to be alone
a lot and so it feels like we're
variants you mean like I'm superintended
ooh [ __ ] I don't feel like you can be
your complete self without hiding any
aspect of yourself being alone is very
comfortable to me yeah so comfort so
like to be with him and to have that
same feeling is like maximum comfort so
maybe he should have heard being with
you is comfortable no that's me that's
just like more powerful because it just
means more to me I guess yeah and on
that note
speaking of smell yeah you don't want a
powerful lucky tried native deodorant
because I don't know if they have
sandalwood and scotch tape yet but they
do have cocoa butter and vanilla what
the coconut cucumber mint lavender and
Rose eucalyptus and mint as well as
limited edition seasonal cents maybe
they should consider the scotch tape and
sandalwood people love it because they
have over I mean they have eight
thousand five star reviews been featured
on TV and in print native is aluminum
free safe and effective there's also
free returns and exchanges in the USA so
no risk to try it and for 20% off your
first purchase you can visit the native
deodorant calm and use promo code b-tch
during checkout once again that's 20%
off your first purchase by visiting
native deodorant comm and using promo
code b-tch during checkout yes I
absolutely love the smell I think this
is actually my favorite smell coconut
and vanilla it's it's she doesn't like
me
I was scout with Katie - your herpes yes
yeah I love it okay
knock knock who's there dingdong ditch
dingdong [ __ ] it's me with your food
open up did you just get five dollars
off yes you did cuz you use our code to
get some hot fresh food what do you want
right now Pizza Chinese Italian I was
busted - mmmm
because I would also take some dim sum
right now can we order door - right now
we're about to for lunch I think that's
a good idea
yep you love to cook but you're not in
the mood to do the dishes tonight watch
your favorite show with your favorite
people instead and get it delivered with
order seriously like if you live in a
big city and I believe it's in it's in a
lot of different cities right now
they're expanding really fast they have
almost every restaurant in the city like
whatever you feel like just scroll
through just scroll through you're gonna
pick you're gonna find something that
you want and ordering is so easy pick
the restaurant pick what you want to eat
ask your boy you want to throw in on
this order and then venmo me man I think
what you want hit into your information
put our code in and hit deliver right
now our listeners can get five dollars
off of their first order of fifteen
dollars tomorrow when you download the
door - app and enter the promo code hey
girl
that's H ey GI RL that's five dollars
off your first order when you download
the door - app from the App Store and
into the promo code hey girl
again that's promo code hey girl five
dollars off your first order from door -
hey girl hey dude I mean I'm like
honestly I know that you guys are
married but I also curious what you guys
are looking very accurate list it for me
really yeah I think just - for our
listeners you know like if you like Geo
if you like you know I love a girl like
Geo
what does Geo like if you love a girl
like Nicki what does Nicki leg if you
love a girl like Megan you want to be
the guy
what is Megan life yeah that's why I'm
kind of curious about you mates to my
must must must must
I won't stray from they have to be
athletic like I need an athletic body I
need to feel like this person's capable
and if they don't have that like
everything else kind of goes to [ __ ] how
many of you guys are really into
athletics not a checkbook I don't have a
physical type
it's always only been sense of humor
like a dark sense of humor and like deep
conversations yeah and then like they
got a good Nick like if you're good in
bed not a big dick but like you know
like they're good with their dick like
they're good in bed yeah your physical
body type like free don't have no how
about you Megan
I got my updated fat guys skinny guys
guys tall guys athletes to those guys
isn't just a physical type though it's
like a mindset so I like the mindset I
like the dedication I like that they are
sticking to goals I like that they said
all of that kind of encompasses the dude
that I want sure yeah that makes sense
yeah I think I should refocus on what I
what mine is because like in my tracker
here's like tall white guys that like
probably couldn't survive outside yes
you're right you do stick to that yeah
okay that's I have some work to do I
guess there's nothing wrong with that
though why are you saying no where are
they found one that stuck around
probably dead
maybe not outside because they couldn't
make it have you is it that you are like
hey I don't want to seriously date yet
because I want to be like you know I
want to be kind of removed or is it like
they're not the right guy to seriously
date each I think it's that one yeah I
mean the the guy that I did before this
was like pretty tragic but he was like I
want to fall in love with someone like
truly madly deeply and I want that
person to be you and he was a
garden-style do you love me he asked me
that straight up whoa ouch hot wait how
long were you had you guys been seeing
each other at this point
I mean long enough to have been dating
but like I was always so scared of
commitment that every time I would get
to the point of being exclusive I'd be
like nah I'm out here and
is so just like scary to commit because
commitment to me means forever and night
but it's like such an archaic way of
thinking but I'm like I'm not gonna
waste my time again in a four-year
relationship if I'm not gonna get
married it should be the mindset I think
too many people don't have that mindset
they just see dating as dating as dating
and it's like I need like an end goal
like if your goal it like you want to
settle down with someone you want a
family and stuff not everyone does but
like if those are your angles and you
definitely like have to have a partner
that sees it the same way like and I do
feel like when you know you know because
like I'm Steve I said I love you in ten
days I know I love your first date - I
love you it was ten days and I just knew
and I was like you don't have to say it
back I don't need you to but I need you
to know that my level is I love you I'm
in love with you I could spend the rest
of my life with you sorry I'd be like
I'd be like she's real hot but this
[ __ ] is crazy
for four years first because I was like
not a movie premiere and you're like wow
let's go out let's have dinner and in
like a third date you're like I'm in
love with you I was like you know I felt
it we made love and I had never made
love before ever like I had never known
what that even meant I think I thought I
had before but then when we did it I was
like whoa like I actually felt so
connected and intimate and I felt like
this person is my soul mate and and that
was the second time we had sex and I
just had I felt I love you from that
moment but I waited like a week before
actually like nice hell yeah yeah that
same for guarding on same exact thing
like we were friends first and then we
didn't really like each other like at
all like I thought he was actually
really [ __ ] annoying yeah and then we
get snowed in we have were forced into
like having a conversation and then the
universe really wanted really
it was [ __ ] rough I mean because
we're so stubborn and then the next
night I like I literally told him hey
Bart um never mind because I wanted to
tell him like I've never was compelled
to
tell anyone I love them and then I want
it I just it needed to come out and I
and I just stopped myself and then he
goes he goes yeah I feel that about you
to know like wild whistle was Bart the
first person you ever said I love you
too I mean I've said it before because I
that's just the thing you're supposed to
say yeah and I just it felt [ __ ] up if
I didn't say it back but this is the
first person I actually meant to tell -
yeah and like everyone else I didn't
want to marry I'm like I'm too focused
on career I don't I don't have time for
this [ __ ] but with him it was like oh
[ __ ] Wow that's awesome
that's amazing my god I've said it four
times but each time I really thought
like I could marry this guy not like I
believe that but I don't think until
Steve I knew what it really felt like
like to be deeply in love and have it
reciprocated and into like know that
that person has your back as much as you
have their back yeah before it was like
I had their back 100% I love you you
know but it didn't feel like how do you
explain that though like how do you
explain that like like when you know you
know yeah like how do you break that
down so ineffable I feel like you I
can't I can't explain it because a lot
of people don't even believe in that oh
yeah a lot of people if you haven't
experienced it you're just like I don't
really think that exists that's a movie
thing and they go the rest of life is
not thinking it exists so they settle
down with someone and they don't really
feel that ever and I feel bad for that
and I want everyone to have feel this
feeling but it's it's like feeling like
you you've known someone all of your
life and maybe even before your life
it's like you look in their eyes and
like they're family like you're so
connected that it I don't know how else
explain it like luggage feels like this
knowing right and I think that like
we've talked about this before and I
think that's the reason why I don't get
into these relationships where like
they're good dudes they're doing well
for themselves they can treat me right
but it's like since it's not that but
you've told me about before I go it's
not it and I'm like damn is that bad
maybe maybe the fact that it's out the
fact that like it's possible is like why
wouldn't I go for right why would I
settle down with someone that's yeah
percent agree with that yeah like it I
was ready to like be single forever
until I could find that feeling and I
didn't think it was gonna come that fast
I was really planning on having like a
good five years of being single or
something but yeah it was just great
timing that he got out of a long
relationship around the same time and we
connected like really hard on that first
date but I don't know I think that
another problem is or something that I
think about sometimes is if we had gone
on a date the first time I met him like
if we hadn't been in serious
relationship separately and we actually
did go on a date when I met him I I was
kind of the same as Bart where like I
thought he was kind of douchey like he
was kind of mean to me in the beginning
and like in a like I like to roast
people but he was like extra Rosie and I
feel like he always like really picked
on me and it made me feel like bad like
sometimes I would go to the bathroom and
cry because oh she was like it was like
because I'm stupid and he won't let it
go and and yeah so I don't I don't know
maybe if we got got on a date then I
might have written him off and been like
missing it yeah you know but it was
after like years of friendship and
working together and we were working on
the specific video Valentine's Day video
and it was a three day shoot where I got
to like learn his sentimental side and
like he's really caring side his
romantic side and I was like whoa this
is not the guy that I thought it was and
you loved exactly how I loved it's too
bad my boyfriend and your girlfriend
don't feel the same way about us it's
totally and then yeah we both got kind
of broken up with in the same way and
that's interesting like the way that you
love has to be the same but like love
languages like truly matter so important
I like if you're if you're the person
that you're dating is giving you love in
the way that they receive it but you
don't speak that language yeah yeah I'd
be like they don't care about us
dude one of the hardest things ever was
like mind you to ask me very like I mean
dude like months months into it he said
hey let's take this quiz what's your
love language oh my god yeah and I was
like I was like mmm
yeah it's mark that is I don't know how
you are mega but for me like our love is
almost like very like strategic it's
almost like a partnership like we're
like little robot people that are like
highly sensitive and emotional but that
I don't think it's necessary it can just
I don't know it's really weird so we
kind of like we communicate like in just
very almost like robotic ways but it
works for us and then I think that our
bond is that we're a team and we do
really amazing things together we
inspire each other constantly and for me
like that's this has been the most
impactful and maybe I'm young and I just
haven't had that like look into his eyes
but like that [ __ ] sounds so [ __ ]
wack to me what what is your love
language my love language is words of
affirmation but I think that that comes
from I've on the internet and so since I
couldn't like have like love and quality
time and stuff I needed to like hear
things to know that like you know
somebody I had like internet
relationships all through my teenage
years so I think that's where that came
from but then my second one is quality
time yeah when you have an internet
relationship like did you see them or
you like like they would I when I was 16
I flew my boyfriend out whoa yeah you
know so yeah so he didn't but I was also
I was content with it because like I
don't need a lot you know I don't I have
so much emotion in my own body I don't
[ __ ] need your cuz I feel like I
relate to you but I had the opposite
effect so like I had internet
relationships only and my parents were
never there I was always alone but I
think that's why I craved quality time
and physical touch and access service
and quality member my top two and then
physical so just like right underneath
I'm just very needy but Mr your language
yeah not gift-giving I don't like that
and like words of affirmations like
pretty glow on the bottom so if someone
if Steve goes like I know you love
pumpkin pie and this like I brought this
for you you would be like okay cool yeah
oh okay yeah it's I mean it's nice that
he thought about me but more like if I
come home and you clean the whole house
like
like he loves me right and then what was
the other thing you said oh yeah the
emotional thing I'm super emotional I go
through the gamut of emotions on a daily
basis but I think Steve is the perfect
balance of like letting me have space
and then I can go to him and get hugs
whenever I want like it's a good like
balance like where he's not smothering
and he's also there for me yeah they're
trying but it's the opposite effect yeah
yeah that's really interesting what's
your love language Megan I am Megan I
used to be acts of service top but yeah
I like [ __ ] being gone it's it's just
like there's already so much to do like
if you could help me in any way because
you know that I'm like dying then like
that's so nice you care about me enough
to like do some like wash the dishes or
like pick something up for leverage some
of the stuff that's like troubling me
right like there's so much like I mean
we do this to ourselves so like me maybe
we don't take on so much [ __ ] we
wouldn't need this but quality time and
recently words of affirmation physical
touch is like the least like physical
gift giving is so low like the last guy
I dated he I was like so weird about PDA
for some reason I mean probably cuz I
wasn't committed you know like you can't
claim me and so he would be out and he
would like touch my back and I just like
I'll play it off but like don't lose
like scoop for there no there was
something on the sidewalk but like no
like don't touch me no uh-uh but then I
was like I was trying to communicate
with him I was like hey physical search
doesn't like work for me in public but
then like behind closed doors I'm
whatever so I was like if whenever you
have the urge to touch me was I don't
but like you could say like tell me with
your work I like I'm gonna get my hand
and rub it down the small of your back
like a guy like running his knuckles
down your lower back holy-o's like no
but like many of you no wonder you don't
want to be tied
I'm guys do that before where they like
think they're like I'm like not like
narrating what they're doing not stage
direction but like instead of instead of
touching me telling me like how they
feel about me like oh I would touch you
right now but like I just want to let
you know that like I think you are
intelligent and caring and wise beyond
belief so words yeah yeah that's how I
learned that I was words of affirmation
when I was like I would take your words
versus your hands oh okay so I realized
this a while ago I think that men are
horrible at communicating so for me
words about formation is also so
powerful because the guys I date I get
like a real sense of genuineness from
them like beforehand that's an
attractive piece of me so when they say
that I feel like they mean it which like
it's like words of affirmation it's like
really good for me I'm like this was
hard for you to say in our [ __ ] love
I think that's how I am as a love Giver
I could never date someone who needed
the words of affirmation because I just
can't give praise unless I really
genuinely mean it's impressive and like
I have to I have to tell you what a good
job you did interesting like other than
that I just have really high standards I
guess I'm like I expect this level so
you don't get any praise for the being
his level or like what the baseline I
feel terrible but that's how I was
raised like my dad would only tell me
what was wrong or what I did wrong he
never really liked my either one number
one mean it makes sense yeah you want it
because you didn't get it right and then
how are you gonna give it when you're
not used to it right yeah give some that
have love's I'm the same way I can't
imagine going like I not not that I
can't imagine have done it but it's
harder for me to give words of like
praise and stuff because I'm just like
no I need back yeah you yeah yeah yeah
and I and I don't know how to do it and
then it just like unless I really feel
it in my [ __ ] yeah or where I'm like
I gotta tell you this was awesome yeah
do you very rarely will be like oh good
like good [ __ ] like good job or
something like that but like she will
occasionally like I'm trying to imagine
Nicki being like good job and like my
mind just goes
[Laughter]
empathize with Steve absolutely when I
give him praise for I think he's like
whoa you meant it
well yeah Wow this is actually you
monster that's hilarious I feel like
with words of affirmation cuz like also
I didn't get it so but like I give what
I want back so like I'll tell the boys
all the nice things of like how smart
and funny they are and how great in
hopes that it comes back and it doesn't
oh so I'm like a funny person that yea
understands goes oh I see and I upon you
back just ping-pong me does question
does like dis career matter at all for
you I feel like as I get older that you
know that's a question for me now yeah I
mean this is something that I've been
talking about therapists for years about
but like since I was so career forward
on in all of my 20s like I all of my
relationships basically failed because
career was first it was before them and
so now that I'm old enough to like I
feel OK in my career I don't really care
anymore
it's really about the connection but
then again the people that are in my
circle and like the people that you
vibrate with like are probably gonna be
on the same level of like career-minded
I mean in my experience yeah so like all
the stand-ups I date like are successful
like whatever the podcast people whoever
it is like they're successful no one's
like can't make their rent or anything
like that yeah
yeah and one of these days you're gonna
find someone that you can call honey and
let me tell you about honey honey is a
service that you can use that helps you
save money honey helps you save money
bars it's to remember so it's a browser
extension and when so let's say you're
shopping online out one of your favorite
stores and you go to checkout you hit
this honey button and it runs through
all these lists of codes that everyone
has used to save money and like get
discounts and it will find you the best
code that will save you the most money
and I think that's so cool I've saved
one of them I saved 50% off of my
checkout order I was shocked
yeah so it's worth it it's free you just
like download it and put it on the
extension extension and then you just
shop like normal and then
the honey mines you saving my favorite
part is when that little bar is like
searching for savings and I'm like yeah
give me give mom a 20 per cig and then
like it'll pop up it'll be like 35% save
and I'm like what the [ __ ] yeah check
out yeah and there's certain retailers
that like I find you can get more codes
from and so I'll like specifically shop
at those retailers because I know that
honey will find discounts oh you got
strategy oh you want me to say them okay
I wasn't sure if I was allowed to
mention other brands but Lulu's mmm
Wayfarer
oh I'm dropping these names Urban
Outfitters sometimes sometimes and get
the wayfarer discount yeah percent off
furniture is [ __ ] expensive it gets
me hard the honey's found it's 10
million users over a billion dollars in
savings total that's crazy
yeah okay so listen there's really no
reason not to use honey it's free to use
and installs on your computer in just
two clicks get honey for free at join
honey calm slash b tch that's join honey
calm slash b tch use our referral code
if you downloading it y'all use it
help your boys out well this one's
definitely not for the boys this one's
definitely for the girls I'm gonna
introduce our next sponsor I'm sorry is
it yes girl did you know that women die
every day using cameras or chemicals in
them well guess what that's not
happening with Lola these are entirely
organic what kind of that's right
that was the trick Geo there's no extra
ingredient it's just organic cop [ __ ]
I'm so sorry thank you for that yes
organic I've even heard root-like rumors
have it that like they put chemicals in
the tampons that like make your period
longer yeah yeah I don't know it's true
but then when you go organic no one's
claiming this but I have heard from
personal friends that are like my period
got shorter mmm I mean look my thing is
is that like what's in them tampons yeah
nobody has to write it on there
in you putting it up there yep so that
makes your month a little bit easier our
subscription is fully customizable you
can choose from your mix of products mix
of absorbency number of boxes and
frequency of delivery it's a full-on
vagina service it is girl what else they
have it clean and organic lova now
offers cleansing wipes and they are safe
to use anywhere on the body so I mean
keep it clean that's right boys wash
their dick in the sink you can just wipe
it up wipe it up that's the thing yeah
okay well then it is for the boys I'm
sorry hey boys come back listen you can
use this too so for all of you guys
listening right now you guys get three
percent off your first month the scrip
this month's goddamn scrip subscription
visit my Lola com enter code beat PCH
when you subscribe yes you know Lola
also means grandma and it does the
Philippines yeah good for you guys today
we have a connection
yes so where were we the guys the ideal
version of guy so you're not in are you
you would rather like take your time and
find the person that is like this dude
that gets you that has your love
language that speaks to your soul then
like being a rush to settle down yeah
but then are getting I really like after
my last relationship I really did like a
lot of self work and I was like alone
and good alone and now I'm like okay
whoever's gonna be in my ether even if
it's not the right one I can like work I
can still continue to do the work of
like what are they teaching me about
myself what can I learn from them what
can I learn from our dynamic that isn't
working like how can this still work for
the better of me and of this other
person I'm so glad you brought that up
because not enough people talk about
that that they're everyone's very
concerned with how do I find the guy how
do I find the right one how do I find
the girl but they don't do any work on
themselves
oh yeah be the person you're trying to
attract yeah and I think that's so
important
I saw one of those little eyes follow so
many these little like psychology meme
okay oh my god me too okay cool it's
like sometimes I just need that little
one-liner
sometimes do all my entire feet is that
now just like therapist this holistic
that or
or like mindset therapy yeah yeah yeah
yeah happiness Journal yeah I'm so into
that the one today
said the issue is you're you're looking
for someone to love you more than you
will love yourself oh yeah and it's like
yes I have been doing that like I'm
always like oh this person's gonna save
me from me this person's gonna save me
from being insecure supposed to just
save me for not actually loving myself
but like no popular mentality yeah what
and it's also being very self-aware and
knowing that those are the things that
you're seeking out because I'm like I'm
trying to like think because I've been
out of the [ __ ] dating it for so long
where I'm like in the past at least I
would try to make it work with the
person cuz I'm like well they can get
there they have enough qualities that I
appreciate that I'm like okay well
there's something kind of missing but I
think I can make it work yeah instead of
feeling like them bringing you up it's
you like lugging them yeah and I didn't
realize yeah I never realized I just
thought that's what you're supposed to
do like I'm in a better place that they
are so I can just bring them up to where
I'm at and then we can kind of just work
on it and become like this like
partnership and I think it's because
I'll like so much is out there that's
like relationships are work
relationships are work and it's like
dragged into you like relationships are
work and marriage is not fun and yeah
and it's it's not doesn't have to be
that way I think it's just a lot of
people are mismatching or like they're
not taking the time to work on
themselves and like figure out who they
are and what makes them happy alone
before like having someone else enter
and just you add to that yeah instead
they're looking for someone to fulfill
all the things that they feel are
missing in themselves
yeah and it's it's like it's so sad that
like I want people to feel that they can
yeah how they have their person lifts
them yeah right um I have my friend
Shannon mudram I'm gonna drop her book
she just put out a book him a desire and
I mean of course she's my little [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna listen to her book I
didn't get to read Abbaye I heard the
whole thing
and one of the things that she did where
I'm like oh that's interesting I want to
learn more about myself is she has this
exercise where you go and you try to
reconnect whether that's the email in
person or whatever it with all of your
exes and you say hey like why do you
think we didn't work oh my god
I love this I always talk about this I
talk about relationship breakups surveys
yeah because I'm not like like an echo
survey
yes and
an interview of like what went wrong yes
what went right any feedback yeah that
would be awesome
have you done it no talking about it we
raise II um I don't think no it's just
if the people aren't on that level
self-aware enough to like kind of also
detach from it should be like this is
what was going on I mean I guess I have
done it once an ex-boyfriend came back
after six years and we just reconnected
the other day huge news in this world
yeah and we were like we talked about it
but not on purpose we were like oh we
were so young everything was petty we
really shouldn't have done this sorry
for yelling at you I thought that's
awesome yeah but it wasn't really I mean
I guess so it was that without trying to
be yeah yeah so she record what's up us
oh I'll chime then I have like a really
dark turn okay no no I was just saying
like I thought that was really really
cool cuz when Bart and I were kind of
having like our dark phases of our
relationship we had like this really
deep like conversation that took like
[ __ ] a whole day of just us talking
and trying to uncover things and pulling
these arrows out and then we we felt so
relieved at the end of it that we were
like oh [ __ ] I think we should reconnect
with our exes and tell them like hey
sorry if I was [ __ ] in this type of
way and it was like very therapeutic yes
it's not the surfing part of it but it
is like it reached out to your ex yeah
every single ex and I was like hey sorry
if I was ever really shitty with you I
was really young and I just explained my
side of things not that I recall like a
lot of the memories of it but just the
feeling of the relationship so I put
that out there and it just kind of
opened up like the the door for them to
be like oh you know what don't worry
about it I was actually doing this and
it was like a cool like did you like you
carried a little bit of a burden at all
from maybe some of the bad things you
felt like you had done in relationships
um I don't know if I thought about it
that deeply I kind of I kind of did so
so I was the problem in all of my
relationships but it came from something
really really bad that I realized maybe
a year and a half ago
long story short when I was in fifth
grade I dated a guy named Josh I was
absent from school one day and I came
back to school and everyone was like
josh is dating Zoey now and that was
Mark so yeah that was my end job
it was my best friend [ __ ] so I felt it
but this isn't 5th grade and that was my
very first relationship well fast
forward to ninth grade I dated a guy I
was 15 he was 18 after 9 months he broke
up with me cold out of nowhere I was
head over heels in love and it just
ended and there was no coming back from
that and that had also happened to me
again in fifth grade so what happened
was for the next 10 years of my life I
recreated this relationship with
everyone that I dated oh I just got
chills
yeah it was it was really bad I dated a
guy when I was 18 and he loved me and I
cut him off cold like yeah in the middle
of it because that's what I'm gonna do
it first before they did it to you yes
and that's also what I was taught love
was like this will happen to me every
time and I could not bear that hurt
again so I recreated a not one and then
when I was 20 I did it with somebody
else and then I didn't really date after
that for a few years and with the guy
I'm dating now there was a point where I
thought I was gonna do it again and it
and I cared about this guy so much and I
realized I was like wait why am I doing
this why am I doing this I had to go
back to the guy when I was 18 I found
him on Facebook and I'd straight-up told
him I was like hey where did this come
from why did you do this to me was it
malicious was it me or what's going on
in your life and he told me it wasn't
you it was you know this is going on in
my life I was you know 18 I was confused
this is this and it relieved me of that
curse that had like been put on me for
10 years it [ __ ] up all the
relationships so like I mean I and I
kind of just say that like us a lesson
that like something that dark probably
is gonna happen to everyone but you
maybe somebody may have created for you
what love what is and you may be
re-enacting that you may be reacting to
that and you as you get older some of
the tools that got you through life when
you were younger you have to change all
those tools
yeah like when you're it like later in
your 20s and when you're in your 30s you
need new tools too because the same
things that served you when you were 15
to protect you
it does not work out ten years later and
if you censor yourself and that goes for
a lot of things even outside of love if
you sense yourself in some kind of
pattern
you really have to tackle that and like
figure out like where is this coming
from and sometimes you have to go back
to your past and release it absolutely
and you don't always have to talk to the
person but I study relationships Journal
yeah
what did you do what did they do and you
also give yourself some credit because
you're older now and you can see things
differently so that's that's dark at all
yeah it's very good even like when
you're below six like you develop coping
mechanisms when you're a baby and
sometimes you don't realize that you
brought those into adulthood and that's
what a good psychologist is for yes they
can unpack all of that and like rewire
your mindset in the way that you
approach life I think that's really
healthy for anybody to go through mm-hmm
like if you have things that you were
doing in a relationship at 15 16 18 if
you are still doing those at 28 hold the
[ __ ] up like you have to look at
yourself and you'll have to do it for
yourself to better yourself and not
bring that into a relationship not to
bring that into a job not to bring that
into it because everything's a
relationship but yeah I saw they were
met like we have a relationship right
and and it's the same thing you have to
uphold yeah and take responsible and I
was reading that sometimes similar to
that even friendships you tend to recast
the same situations over and over again
in your life if you don't recognize the
pattern and break it and journaling is
really helpful for that because when
you're going through something you can
look back and see if you're actually
repeating a pattern and it's something
that you can change and take
responsibility for which I think is
really cool bringing it back to what you
look for in a guy because I just want to
share and Megan already knows as I've
shared this before but I might have
shared it on this podcast before but
share it with me though yeah but how I
wrote down like that I wanted to find a
guy exactly like Steve green and then
three months later we were dating and I
didn't know it was gonna be him but I
was like if someone out there can find
that type of guy I can too and I was
like I want exactly that type of guy
dude that's not saying you have to drop
a name but I did that with Bart really I
just realized yeah like okay so I had
just gotten out in a relationship or
snowed in we had to talk so I'm all
crying cuz I'm like saying I wasted so
much [ __ ] like like three years on
this [ __ ] ex-boyfriend of mine he
sucked and then I felt so relieved
talking to him and I was like man
there's hope because there's a guy like
you out there I want to find myself
apart I said that out loud to him yeah
stoppie I'm sorry so Megan just putting
it out to the universe what would that
be
Oh like who just a summary that's like
yeah I could not stop until I find this
guy she's like a Brad Pitt no honestly
out I will name a celebrity just so ya
hear me of anybody that we know yeah but
like a John Mulaney type who definitely
would not survive overnight yeah funny
but not like a super pessimistic not a
super physic funny he also grew up in
the church and then is not Catholic
anymore so hello here we are and then he
like the way that he talks about his
wife is so beautiful like he was he's
really behind and here's my new
background okay and he's like cute like
cute we did you break up with Bo I do
love a good bow burn her obsession
that's like her Eminem
I feel like Bo Burnham is like just a
wacky guy he's but he's I'm sure yeah
special I don't know I just picture
whenever Bo Burnham walks he like goes
like this really his left eye got a
complete oh yeah don't yolk her yeah I'm
dude I didn't say that's a bad thing
it's just a bum okay then I did I'm
sorry yeah yeah yeah Bo's my somebody
says something not racist and you're
like hey don't be racist you're like
what deeply analytical person oh yeah
turns it into humor which is like very
attractive I can totally see why he is
your type yeah but yeah at this time who
you named John Mulaney I'm like wow Bo's
got some competition yeah those would be
great someone nothing a mash-up of them
yeah yeah all right well universe
hearing that are you hearing this
universe ringing yeah and that's a while
because you would think like Megan right
like she's like the super hot chick that
would have everyone knocking at her door
all the time I mean we're all super hot
chicks you know honestly yes
yeah and to be like like [ __ ] no no I'm
sure she's not at a shortage of people
knocking at her door just like the Koala
come on the right one yeah I know I know
but people think like it should be easy
you know you're just so hot it should be
easy
yeah I would picture you with like the
rock oh no people have too many muscles
I'm like I can't do that say yeah my
sister and I have such different type
like I want your arm to be like one limb
not like six [ __ ] like pieces of
muscle like I don't want that I think I
have to do it I'm feeling like home when
they hug you or when you are like
cuddled thanks to them I need it to feel
like a little comfy not like rock hard
solid oh no I need I need a [ __ ] four
tree I did [ __ ] you know right
penetrable yeah yeah I wonder if it's
because like you're so like Amazonian
like you're tall and strong already like
fury stirs you can't have like a puny I
can't no because I just have such as
like a like a strong personality and
like yeah that I'd be like oh my god
you're my [ __ ] and I can't yeah that
makes so much sense I when Steve and I
first start dating I had trouble because
he had just lost like 30 pounds because
I agree I saw his YouTube video knee is
why yeah that was like you're skinnier
than me it feels weird because you're
like Pelotas bone is going into my thigh
and I don't have a pelvis bone for you
then you gain some way put some fat on
that boy Filipino cooking yeah you know
why yeah I bet something like came in
and I'm like I'm gonna go leave no I do
have a face when I'm about to say
something it's like [ __ ] doubt so
Raven I'm like this like it's a really
oh she's a bit clot twist I've got
nothing George could have the patron
but yes it's it's uh it's tough out
there folks do I want to know I feel
like you've never talked about this
before Gio maybe you have maybe I make a
good guest can't imagine that what else
having sex
absolutely well where did because she
was saying remember that JK and use
episode which is like I can picture
Steve and Nikki like I can even hear
them hugging and doing all that oh yeah
absolutely [ __ ] weird first of all
but what are like yeah but I want to
know what was the guy that you dated
before Bart like uh so he was very
Korean like a very Korean but muscley uh
he was very athletic
yeah and not as athletic as Bart okay
definitely athletic he was six six one
she was taller
he was very goal-oriented he wanted to
like he was he was going to SC like he
had like his business plans all set up
ready to go but he was just very Korean
oh yeah you have a you're goal-oriented
athletic yeah like Asian my exes were
just like Megan's exes like are they
single now I'm not down I don't have
that I know of Nikki's I met him at a
party and he was dressed up like the
duffy man from the scene and he was
handing out the shittiest gifts I've
ever seen it was like magnets or
something but they had like little bows
on them like for Christmas it was so so
that that's my impressions of Nicki I
don't know any of your exes yeah and you
like need to describe they're bad
they're toxic people him I I don't like
to really talk much about him anybody
like that just the type I feel like so
what attracted to me to them is the dark
humor
personally the would able ability to
deliver jokes she said
[Laughter]
what you thought you were in on the joke
even more natural it's like she's like
the dark seat remember your lamp mm-hmm
yeah so that ability to deliver a joke
dryly where you don't know like where
it's it doesn't hey I'm making a joke
right now it's like a dry humor joke I
really like that I also think it to me
is like this display of confidence in a
way we're like you are so like
comfortable with people not knowing if
you're joking or not and it and I like
it's just a specific type of humor that
I really get and understand it doesn't
matter what they look like or like who
they are as a person like that just
makes me fall in love with them
immediately and then usually because
this is coming from a dark place like
the way they're able to have such dry
dark cynical humor is because they have
a dark place that darkness is what
destroys the relationship it's very
toxic
a lot of narcissism like I found out
later that I can be codependent when I'm
with a narcissist and that's like a
toxic relationship yes yeah and so like
they need me to fulfill their narcissism
and I need them to validate me by
because they're with me and they're you
know I don't know it's a weird thing you
could look it up that like whole bond
that happens but yeah when the cool
thing is when you get out of a
relationship like that you can stop
being codependent but narcissists can't
really stop being narcissists so Wow
yeah Megan any common denominators with
your exes oh my god it's so hard to like
think about them because I just never
think about them anymore but I guess I
mean they're all really sweet guys like
there's none of them are mean and I
think that's like I won't date you if
you're mean that's a deal breaker
they're all really nice I mean they all
like liked me too much and that was like
kind of the the thing that I couldn't
get down with I just felt like they
liked them more than I liked them and it
was unfair is it because the pacing was
faster than your pacing like where you
could have probably liked them that
amount but they were moving too fast for
you yeah I that to my longest
relationships I was forced into one of
them gave me like a deadline they're
like you'll be my girlfriend by December
and I'll like work we'll see about that
and then I like ultimatum or something
it was I mean it was just like I don't
know maybe he was like very confident
yeah baby and that's pretty humor humor
but confidence yeah I'd be like Oh will
I I'm like I will yeah I already got me
and then the long long one like we only
we really committed when he like drove
eight hours to tell me that he loved me
when I was like on a job and it's like
these guys doing like these Jim Halpert
moves to make me be like yes this is the
one and that's something I'm dealing
with now is I think that I've been
programmed for these men to like be
going above and beyond so that if the
people I'm dating now aren't like doing
the most I'm like oh you don't care
you're not you're not working me like
grandiose jesters are like
subconsciously yeah no you're not like
for now with that mindset yeah no and I
don't want to be like that but like
that's what I you what you ain't used to
you recognize it now so therefore you
can cut it off faster totally yeah yeah
it just Oh God
I mean I but that's like that makes me
feel taken care of right that no I I
agree in like won't Steve and I first
try dating we were both like that we're
like I was doing Jim Halpert moves and
he was too and like they were matching I
was like well yeah we were just really
trying to blow each other out of the
water
right but then after like you know a
year or so were like hey so we're both
impressed by each other right so let's
just like drop it like let's just save
our money for like cool things like
trips and stuff yeah so that's what we
do downs like we don't do like crazy
birthdays or gifts or anniversaries or
anything but we save it and go on like
an end-of-the-year trip and we write
like that a lot but in the beginning I
do agree like those things do impress
and totally it's like a swoon and like
you're being courted and like totally
this guy like cares enough to see it to
value you and like see what you like and
match it yeah I see any sort of like
correlation or pattern with like
relationships that go a little bit past
three years like
I've been noticing year and a half for
me really I think that year and a half
is the make-or-break at point-o me I
mean it's three like if I can get to the
three and we get past it then [ __ ] gets
really [ __ ] patient up I know yours I
know I've only dated like I feel like
three yeah that's not working oh I don't
know I think it can be comfortable the
first year right like it's still puppy
luggage yeah covering so much and
especially if you don't live together
yeah like for your one-and-a-half is it
lifting true like I usually move in
pretty quickly yeah maybe if you didn't
it would be the three-year mark I feel
like in or after three years see that's
why I'm moving in because it speeds up
whether or not you should break up
I agree oh okay yeah oh wow yeah because
all these little things that you lived
with anyone deal yeah
okay I was forced you'll move in by
January and some note it's like all
different letters I'm a girlfriend one
of those that's all of my belongings in
a tiny band a DIY band and but yeah
that's so fascinating because I'm always
like oh I'm not gonna move in with
somebody until like year two and a half
oh you have like a set number yeah I
mean if I were to put a throw one out
okay it felt right it would feel right
but since I did live with someone when I
was 18 it was like no this is horrific
but I guess you're right I mean like the
older I get I'm like yeah you would you
would get to the answer sooner yeah yeah
it's like hard to marriage it's like I
want to test the merchandise out for
exactly so if we move in and I find out
immediately I can't live with you yeah
then we can't get married that's so true
and I and if we move in together it has
to be like in a neutral apartment where
we're moving both yeah so you're not
gonna [ __ ] tell me you gotta get out
of my place yeah [ __ ] you yeah moving
out all this hell no yeah you're not
moving into my place I'm not moving into
yours we don't sign that lease together
that happens to me where so my ex lost
not lost his place but like got laid off
of his job and so he lived around the
corner from me and I was like well you
can just like
crash here you know and then he ended up
working out this thing was like hey if I
pay half the rent like can I live here
and I'm like sure so that one was kind
of like more forced in and then whenever
he didn't pay the rent he'd be like I
was [ __ ] because like it's my name on
the lease so I had to bear all the
responsibility and he often didn't pay
the rent yeah it was that was a weird
situation but yeah I'm in a I feel like
I'm in a spot where like in your and
you're like teens in your early twenties
you're just like yeah love-love bah blah
blah blah and like now that I'm in my
late 20s I'm like you need a job you
need a career trajectory you needed a
savings account and we need to like I
need I need to know what your future
entails whereas before I didn't care it
was just looks personality do we love
each other and now there's this very
adult factor that's like kind of scary
but it happens you know I think as you
get older you develop more standards
yeah because you're ready to like move
on to a next portion of your life which
is like you know force people we need
kids and we need a yeah but thank you so
much Megan for joining the business
today value your [ __ ] presence we
really hope that you find that dude out
there he's out you are gonna find them
and yeah you are there you are though
he's married so happily Megan where can
they find you at Megan Mattoon and I
have my podcast just a tip just a tip I
love her podcasts give it such good
advice yeah yeah okay what is your
dating advice can't close with the
dating advice from ollie are we on just
the tip or in relationship advice in
general yeah if I can just people say
that it's hard work but it really is
hard work but it's uh but it's no it's
like when you're passionate about like a
project and like it doesn't feel like
work it's like this good stress that's
what it's like yeah I'm also work for it
work for it it's not easy work for okay
Nicki you got to work okay so take the
time don't don't rush into a
relationship because you're like what
I'm 28 now gotta start thinking about
marriage because my biological clock
says I need to have kids before 35 and
then I by the time we get married in
blah blah blah like too many people do
that I've heard that so many times like
yeah I don't feel the same way about him
like you and Steve but you guys are
different but like it's time for me to
get married and like it's uh it's not
time for you to get married yeah I'm
pregnant could happen so fun and divorce
is really expensive so just save
yourself save yourself do we just like
save yourself for the right person yeah
okay relationship advice I had time to
think to uh communicate communicate yeah
yeah I think that it's like safe to say
that like nobody is a hundred percent
happy we're all like at times we get a
little down we get a little insecure and
to people that are either feeling down
or insecure that can't communicate is a
[ __ ] train wreck like like dead apps
it's just not gonna happen you know so
be in tune with yourself be in tune with
your partner and try to talk as much as
you can and don't be afraid to express
your feelings because if they run away
from your feelings then they're probably
not right for you
amen God all that [ __ ] you know what's
your got it mine is she was taking a you
it doesn't have to be somebody else that
you're in a relationship with because it
all starts with you starts and ends with
you guys thanks for tuning in subscribe
rate us on iTunes thanks to our sponsors
today Lola native honey and door - you
can get so many discounts on all of
those by using our codes those are all
the descriptions and we'll see you next
time bye [ __ ]